we've embraced weakness of people in
today's society not only have we
embraced it but we we reinforce it you
know when when someone puts a trigger
warning on a video for some reason
that's seemingly normal now I don't
think it's the world's responsibility to
have to adhere to your triggers I think
your triggers are your responsibility
and it's up to you to be able to filter
out what you can and can't take also so
how are we going to move forward if we
have to put trigger warnings on
everything if we've got these people
that are so easily upset and hurt and
offended that they need a trigger
warning on things what is that what is
that actually doing that's wrapping them
in Cotton wool that's not exposing them
to the real world that that's putting
them in a position where they're never
going to be able to handle anything
because they're so protected from
everything